I've owned 1941 yeah where'd you live  Muhammad Charlie now I'm sure you my  opponent even Lebanon yeah sure they're  not picking up in he's from the American  Navy oh yeah right because you speak  great what you sound like you're from  New York yeah just like a chicken bone  Capone yes I'm not gonna better than  yellow your New York Mafia yeah yeah I  like like i remarried in yellow yeah and  you have the nice hair like him yeah  just like a in the young face yeah and i  can see you let you lift you lift  weights yeah  you guys still have each other this  guy's a character yeah yeah  from our tickets  are you meet here man two weeks I never  show not